[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin bTW
science chemistry Phe skincare nerd and
battle rapper wannabes today I thought
it would be interesting to review a
celebrity skincare routine I'm going to
have a look at the products they use and
discuss if it's a good routine from a
scientific point of view if you want me
to review more skincare routines leave
me a comment telling me whose skincare
routine you want me to look at next if
you like this sort of science II take on
Beauty give this video a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel and make sure
you click the notification button so you
don't miss out on any of my videos the
first victim is Pharrell Pharrell
Williams is part of the music production
super team The Neptunes who are pretty
much responsible for the soundtrack to
my undergrad unique news The Neptunes
have also released a few albums as any
ID and Pharrell's also gone on to
release solo music he recently also told
Donald Trump to stop using his song
happy at events which might actually be
weeping for trauma since if you like me
you can probably go another 20 years
without hearing that damn song again
apart from being a musical genius
Pharrell's
also known for never aging
he somehow still looks mostly like he is
in his late 20s or early 30s even though
he's 45 his skin is just really good I
feel kind of creepy looking at his skin
I feel like I'm a lizard person
window-shopping and I like what I see
obviously there's the saying that black
dirt and crack dark skin has melanin
pigment which acts like a sort of
natural sunscreen so it's a lot more
resistant to sun damage which is one of
the biggest reasons that skin starts
looking old but even for a black dude
Pharrell looks really young let's have a
look at his skincare routine and see
what the science says now before we
really get into it here's a few things
that you should keep in mind when we
talk about celebrity skin care routines
we're just going off what he says his
routine is celebrities can usually
afford to go to dermatologists all the
time and get regular facials and
procedures and in fact they probably
need you
since looking good is part of their job
Pharrell has a net worth of 150 million
so he can afford this celebrities also
often have undisclosed partnerships so
they might get paid to mention a product
even though they don't use it at all
there's also genetics different people
have different skin and some people can
do anything to their skin and you'll
still be fine as I've mentioned before
on my video on skincare myths there
could also be other things contributing
to how good their skin is so things like
diet routine whether they meditate a lot
whether they exercise a lot and usually
people don't really associate this with
giving them good skin because of all
these factors that can also influence
your skin these so-called confounding
factors that's why we need to use
science to work out what actually has a
good chance of making a difference for
most people all right let's get into
pharrell skincare routine
[Music]
obviously he's been asked a lot of times
about his skincare routine and
interviews everyone wants to know what
he's doing he uses glide home products
that were recommended by his
dermatologist first in his routine
there's the glide own acne cell foam in
cleanser this has no point 5% salicylic
acid salicylic acid is a beta hydroxy
acid chemical exfoliant it's good for
clearing out your pores and preventing
acne even though the glide tone cleanser
is a wash off product there's some
evidence that wash of products can put
salicylic acid on your skin so other
notable ingredients in this cleanser
apart from the salicylic acid there's
some fluorinated ethers and fluorinated
hexane these ingredients are really good
for trapping oxygen into the product
this is what gives that bubbling cell
foaming effect when it's inside the
container the oxygen bubbles are trapped
inside the product it's dissolved but
when you put it on your skin and rub it
around then it starts fizzing and
bubbling and so that's what gives you
that firming effect which looks a little
bit like you're a sheep or a cloud
there's also some gentle surfactants
which won't disrupt your skin too much
so there's coke emitter protocol beteen
and sodium Lori sulfate there's also a
few humectants in the product like
butylene glycol and sorbitol which can
attract and hold water into the top
layers of your skin to keep it hydrated
despite the cleansing so overall it
looks like it's a pretty nice cleanser
pharrell also uses the glide shown acne
clearing toner which has 2% salicylic
acid so it's got a bit more salicylic
acid and it stays on your skin it looks
like it's a pretty straightforward
salicylic acid product Pharrell's also
mention what products he requests in his
writer one of them is the Cetaphil
cleansing wipes I'm not really liking
the look of these wipes there's a whole
bunch of humectants which I don't think
will be all that cleansing but then
again Pharrell doesn't really look like
he wears that much makeup if any but
these wipes do contain sodium lauryl
sulfate or SLS this is a really
irritating surfactant and I wouldn't use
it in a Levon product it's really small
which means it's good at borrowing into
your skin and causing prolonged
irritation and these effects have been
observed even when it's used in a
cleanser that's washed off afterwards
unlike this product there's a cream
called aqueous cream BP this cream is a
leave on
and it contains SLS and they found that
it caused irritation inflammation and
peeling when it's used in a Levon
product especially in people who have
sensitive skin so with this wipe which
has the SLS in it I would recommend
rinsing it with water after using it but
then it sort of defeats the purpose of
having a wipe
there's also Cetaphil lotion in his
Rider it's got glycerine near the top of
the ingredients list which is really
hydrating it's really good at holding
water close to your skin so that the top
layer stay moist the texture of this
lotion wasn't my favorite it felt like
there was a sort of film over my skin
that didn't quite sink in but this is
more of a personal preference Pharrell's
also mentioned that he exfoliates a lot
a lot a lot I quote to me the key is
just exfoliating like a monster there's
a lot of dead skin all the time like a
narcissistic madman I am a big fan of
exfoliation I wrote a free guide on it
that you can download I also made a
video all about it Pharrell uses a lot
of salicylic acid in his products
already so I'm assuming that with this
exfoliation stuff he's talking about
physical exfoliation this is when you
use products that buff off the surface
of your skin so it helps loosen skin
flakes if you bother bit too hard then
maybe it's not really loose skin there
actually isn't that much dead skin
that's ready to come off so maybe he is
using a peeling gel which makes it look
like there's more skin coming off the
issue I can sort of see with his
description is the possibility of over
exfoliating this is when you go too hard
and your skin loses the important dead
layers that it needs so on my handi skin
model the dead layers the skin the
stratum corneum is this top layer and
you need it to protect all of these
under layers so I recommend that you
build up to Pharrell like levels really
slowly in terms of drinking a lot of
water drinking water hasn't really been
shown to help your skin doctors usually
think that people are too obsessed with
drinking more water there's been lots of
papers about the myths of how much water
you need to drink so for example the
idea that if you're thirsty you're
already dehydrated is a myth for people
who have found benefits to drinking more
water it might not actually be the extra
water that's doing the good it might be
what's leaving your diet when you drink
more water so for example if you're not
drinking soda anymore if you're a bit
fuller so you end up eating less junk
food if it's just
a habit that makes you more conscious of
doing better things for your health like
exercising he also mentions that he
washes with cold water to close his
pores cold water is good because hot
water strips your natural moisturizing
factors and lipids from your skin but
opening and closing your pores using hot
and cold water is a myth
[Music]
the obvious thing that's missing from
Pharrell's routine is sunscreen
sunscreen is a fantastic anti-aging and
anti-cancer product a lot of people with
darker skin don't burn so a lot of the
time they skip sunscreen but black
people do get skin cancer and when they
do it usually isn't detected until later
because it's harder to see he does do
outdoor festivals quite a bit and I feel
like his dermatologist isn't going to
let him not use the sunscreen so maybe
he just doesn't mention it it's possible
that if you're Undead
then maybe your DNA doesn't work the
same way you might have infinite
chilling ears for example or you might
have better DNA repair mechanisms so you
don't get cancer so you don't need to
worry about sunscreen your cells might
not actually replicate at all you might
just keep the same skin the whole time I
couldn't find any Studies on this but
the fact that he exfoliate so much does
suggest that his cells are still
replicating so sunscreen is probably
still a good option for him another
product that I would recommend for older
skin is a resin I'd like tretinoin which
is really good as an anti-aging product
but whatever he is doing is obviously
working well firm so overall Pharrell
has a pretty solid routine it sounds
like a good routine for oily skin it
doesn't recommend anything really stupid
so I'm going to give Pharrell's routine
and a another thing I should mention is
that Pharrell's dermatologist is dr.
Eleanor Jones she is actually written a
chapter in a book about Botox so Botox
might also possibly be part of the
secret to Pharrell's great skin you can
do Botox really subtly so you don't have
that frozen look that might be what's
keeping his wrinkles at bay
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked it please give me a thumbs up
subscribe for more videos like this you
can also follow me on Instagram and
check out my blog for milk beauty
science and see you next time for more
beauty science
you